basically you have the force five six is
seven sleeping with the top percentage
of guys they sleep with them
that's who they really want to be with
then they say okay I need kids I need to
bring I need to get this done so then
they lower their standards and they
think they're better than the guy
they're with and they don't really
respect him
yeah and before that didn't happen
because like people dated more
intentionally even even with the one
night stands and like like people
getting pregnant when they were
teenagers like they just get married
before how many our grandparents got
married through shotgun weddings
like you understand they just were like
oh okay let's get married and
figure it out